[Music]
[Music]
feel the heat
[Music]
river city girls 2.
in 1996 pokemon was daring since then
the core pokemon games have mostly stuck
to the pattern established by those
first games developing a sense of
familiarity with steady light iteration
pokemon legend's arceus breaks that
iterative pattern attempting to
establish a new foundation while
borrowing bits and pieces from the main
pokemon games to create something new
the result is sometimes messy and
doesn't always work but its distinct
quality set it apart from the core
series and ultimately elevate it
[Music]
though it's a spin-off pokemon legend's
arceus isn't lending the pokemon
trappings to an entirely different set
of mechanics like the mystery dungeon or
stadium series instead this game
reimagines pokemon's core mechanics
finding and catching pokemon and
battling with them within the new
context of exploring vast open spaces
legends arcus takes place long before
the modern games at a time when pokemon
haven't become integrated into daily
life as pets and pack animals there's a
sense that the wilderness here is
dangerous and the villagers treat
pokemon like fearsome wild beasts the
exception to this is the survey corps a
small band of burgeoning scientists
working underneath the local security
forces an ever-present rift in the sky
appears to be driving pokemon berserk
including larger than life sacred
pokemon that are given special reverence
and protection by the local diamond and
pearl tribes as a stranger in a strange
land with no other options you join up
with the survey corps in hopes of
solving the mystery of the rift the
survey core's day-to-day work is
building the first pokedex a paper-bound
notebook that compiles all of the
region's accumulated pokemon knowledge
completing your pokedex is always the
goal of pokemon games but it's usually
an incidental secondary goal to
collecting new pokemon in order to train
them for battles in arceus completing
the pokedex is front and center
reintroducing it as a pivotal goal that
connects everything you do including how
you progress through the game
though the process of completing the
pokedex involves similar mechanics to
what's found in the mainline pokemon
games legend's arceus makes it a bit
more involved you can see pokemon
wandering freely around the open
environments but you don't necessarily
need to do battle to engage them you can
quietly sneak up on them and toss a
pokeball at them that's often enough to
catch them so you go through pokeballs
quickly dozens in a single trip building
out your collection the controls behind
this binary approach stealth versus
attack capturing versus initiating a
battle can be disorienting the trigger
button is used to toss whatever you have
at the ready and you toggle between a
menu of pokeballs and kant pokemon using
the x button it's fairly intuitive most
of the time cycling through your arsenal
and then aiming a shot but in the heat
of the moment it's easy to waste a
pokeball when you meant to start a
battle or worse to start a battle when
you were trying to be sneaky
in a mainline pokemon game simply
catching a pokemon would fill out its
pokedex entry but that's not the case
here since you're building the first
pokedex and since the stealth catch
mechanic lends itself to quicker fines
completing a pokedex entry involves
completing a series of tasks a pokedex
sheet will outline tasks often with
multiple tiers like catching a certain
number of pokemon defeating a certain
number and so on once you've completed a
number of these tasks you can turn in
your findings and the pokedex entry is
considered complete it's a remarkably
flexible system that lets you play
pokemon your own way if you love to do
pokemon battles you can make almost all
of your progress just fighting wild
monsters if you'd rather focus on
stealth and barely engage with battles
at all that option is available too
[Applause]
at first i found myself obsessively
checking my pokedex tasks and steering
myself towards min maxing completion but
after a while i found it was much more
enjoyable to just wander the world
stealth catching and battling as i felt
like it and then letting the chips fall
where they may for pokedex completion
unfortunately campaign progress gating
is also gated to completing pokedex
survey results the survey core gives
star rankings that level up as you gain
research points for completing tasks and
filling out pokedex entries new
environments open up as you progress
through the story but between each major
story point you need to rank up to the
next star level that meant for the first
few star ranks i was stuck needing to go
over areas i had already explored
extensively grinding to progress enough
to proceed later in the game once i
gained access to a larger selection of
environments and had access to mounts
that made new areas reachable it was
much easier to progress without feeling
like i had to go back over our previous
area with a fine-tooth comb the battle
system is possibly the most recognizable
aspect from previous pokemon games with
each pokemon in legends arceus only
being able to equip a total of four
moves at a time and all the usual rock
paper scissors elemental matchups intact
but needing to know the finer nuances to
type matchups is de-emphasized in arceus
to the point where moves are just listed
as effective super effective not very
effective and no effect from the start
more recent pokemon games have included
this feature and i appreciate the help
as someone who does not have the brain
space to keep track of every move match
up but it has previously kept those
hints gated behind having a completed
pokedex entry in pokemon legends arceus
that rough edge is sanded down to be
even smoother since you'll see them all
listed right away even the first time
you ever encounter a new pokemon you can
also get into an encounter against
multiple pokemon sometimes just through
sheer luck by starting a battle in the
middle of a crowd of wild creatures
these moments can feel appropriately
harrowing since you can still only have
one monster out at a time and sometimes
you'll simply run into a pokemon far
above your level including red-eyed
alpha pokemon that are larger and more
powerful than the average for their
species if you can catch them they're
essentially the apex predators of their
type with a requisite step bump adding a
small but sometimes vital wrinkle to the
battle system is the option to make any
of your attacks agile or strong an agile
attack sacrifices some strength for
speed which sometimes lets you attack
twice before your opponent can respond
conversely a strong attack will pack
some extra punch but it might slow you
down enough that your opponent can act
twice an optional battle timeline shows
when the turns will occur so you can see
how swapping between agile and strong
moves will affect the turn order this
adds an extra layer of creativity and
strategy especially once you start
supplementing less effective attacks
with strong style because you want to
inflict a status effect or using agile
style on a super effective attack to
finish off an opponent quickly
a series of boss battles called frenzy
battles are also a significant change
from the pokemon norm these large-scale
conflicts tie into the story as you work
with each pokemon's caretaker warden to
learn what kinds of foods they like so
you can make special balms you then go
into a distinct arena where you have to
dodge the rampaging pokemon's attacks
and hit it with bombs only occasionally
sending out your own pokemon to stun it
long enough that you can rapid fire more
bombs at it saving these beasts by
juggling the priorities of active
dodging looking for open opportunities
to throw and then mixing in traditional
pokemon battles is the most exciting the
series has been in years the wardens and
the leaders of their clans are standout
personalities in legends arceus
introducing a totally new cast of
characters but keeping the focus
relatively small pokemon games often
have a fairly sprawling cast of friends
professors gym leaders elite four
members and the champion and we rarely
get to know any of them particularly
well in legends arceus there are less
than a dozen main characters and we
spend much more time with them getting
to know their personalities and how they
clash with each other there's not a
massive amount of depth to the story and
characters but i still got attached to
these cute anime kids the world is
presented similar to breath of the wild
but this game's distinctly separate
zones don't quite match the sprawling
openness of that zelda game they're
still rather large and it captures that
same sense of wonder but it's not the
same level of impressive technical feat
pokemon legends arceus also seems to be
straining against the technical
limitations of the nintendo switch at
times even among these smaller
environments pieces of world geometry
pop in and out somewhat regularly and
bodies of water in the sky show texture
repetition that's hard not to notice
it's a testament to the quality of the
game that those issues only slightly
detracted from my enjoyment some of the
new ideas in arceus have rough edges and
it's a slow start before you get access
to many environments and mounts this is
an awkward first step and it was a big
adjustment for me as a long time fan
once pokemon legend's arceus finds its
stride though it's the most daring and
inventive the series has been in years
breaking apart the state core and
creating something new and exciting from
its pieces
[Music]
[Music]
pokemon legends arceus has been such a
refreshing take on the pokemon formula
dramatically changing what we've gotten
used to over the last 25 years
introducing new elements for players to
explore i've beaten the game and am well
into the end game now and i've compiled
together some interesting things that
i've noticed during my playtime if you
have any easter eggs or anything notable
that i missed drop them in the comments
below i might even grab them and make a
part 2 of this video a quick note that
there will be spoilers from the story so
keep that in mind here are 12 things you
didn't know about pokemon legends arceus
be sure to sub to the channel and like
this video while you're at it now let's
dive in
as you progress through the campaign and
save the hasuy region's various noble
pokemon from their mysterious frenzy
you'll also come across wardens that
teach you how to use these mounts these
mounts have a variety of benefits with
the key bonus being that you'll be able
to access areas that were previously out
of reach you'll start off with the word
year and then eventually an ursuluna
basket legion sneezler and finally a
bravery
one cool thing that you can do though is
you can swap these mounts on the fly
without having to get on and off each
time you can simply press the d-pad to
change your mount at any given moment
and if you were already on a mount and
happen to go into the water for example
you'll immediately swap being in the air
or in free fall or even near a cliff
side will also give you a button prompt
to mount the right pokemon for the
terrain
you know sometimes pokemon break out of
their pokeballs that is a sad fact of
life however there is a tight window of
time where you can immediately throw
another pokeball for a second chance
catch the best way to secure this chance
is by keeping a pokeball at the ready as
soon as the pokemon breaks free you can
toss a ball at it before it even notices
you and either enrages or flees
the animation for the pokeball is
slightly different from the og games
historically the pokeball is supposed to
shake and wobble before being caught
usually three times throughout most of
the past games in legends arceus the
pokeball will dramatically pop up in the
air and emit steam clouds
you can get a quick gauge on the catch
rate and probability of the wild pokemon
being caught based on the amount of
steam high probability catches look like
only one cloud of steam is emitted and
the ball only gives a little pop in the
air while alpha pokemon and other more
difficult to catch pokemon will emit up
to three clouds of steam with the
pokeball launching super high up
now suppose you need a nice break from
the countless quests cutscenes and all
the paris trying to murder you
in that case you can hang out with your
pokemon in the overworld but not near
wild pokemon just find a bit of free
space and throw your pokemon to spawn
out and then stay within the vicinity of
them you can even interact with them and
speak with them it's also not limited to
just one pokemon either toss out your
entire team and watch them all engaged
with each other you can even have your
pokemon interact with those nearby npcs
such as the warm pool or casco and
jubilife throw out a dust talks and see
what it does
now some areas such as the alabaster
icelands will have dynamic weather like
hail or snow storms other areas may have
rain if you need to change the weather
all you have to do is simply rest at
your camp weather can be a boon if you
have pokemon moves that match the type
but it can also be detrimental if you're
using ineffective moves for example my
typhlosion was having trouble using
effective fire moves since the area had
a lot of rain but a quick camp rest
until the rain subsided and now we're
back to our regular strength
now this is an important one because
historically any pokemon involved in a
battle would get xp once the opposing
pokemon fainted this means you would
normally get xp up to 6 times per battle
however that's all been streamlined now
and your entire team will receive a
cumulative xp total at the end of an
encounter most of your encounters will
be with wild pokemon so this is not an
issue still on the rare occasion that
you encounter a noble or battle of
trainer be sure to keep in mind that if
any of your pokemon are fainted by the
end they will not receive any xp
regardless of their contributions
throughout the battle
being poisoned paralyzed or asleep used
to be a major annoyance after a battle
ended but now all status effects are
temporary whether you use an agile
normal or strong move a status effect
will have a certain number of turns
before it wears out
using a status move again will refresh
the counter you can also overwrite
certain status effects for example
causing a burned enemy to now be
paralyzed
maybe you're using stealth rock and you
realize wait this works more like
whirlpool or firespin from the older
games or maybe you notice that the base
power and accuracy of certain moves are
slightly different well you're right
pokemon moves have had a dramatic rework
in legends arceus for example you might
not know that pulse moves like dark
pulse dragon pulse and water pulse now
have a 100
accuracy rate and any kind of slashing
move has a high crit rate regardless of
what it is this means that dragon claw
and x scissor now benefit from a higher
crit rate chance that used to be
exclusive to a move like slash most of
these reworks make sense since there is
no pvp battling in legends arceus some
of these changes are really awesome
though self-destruct for example no
longer completely faints your pokemon
instead it deals closer to like 80 of
self damage
and huge destructive moves like giga
impact or hyper beam no longer require a
recharge either which is wild so you can
just unleash the move back to back moves
like rollout or outrage don't lock you
into using the same move but instead now
state that your pokemon is simply
fixated on the move meaning that using
it again will gain a damage boost but
it's not mandatory not only are the
moves some of the biggest changes with
lots of hidden traits but their
animations look sick as hell too
at some point near the end of the main
campaign you will have a choice to be
accompanied by either the diamond or
pearl clan leader as you embark on the
red chain main request depending on who
you pick that will decide which
legendary pokemon you catch first and
which you will have to battle with bombs
in a noble style boss battle in my
playthrough i picked the pearl clan and
i came face to face with palkia
eventually going back to diago later in
the story to see that dialga actually
adopted a cool origin style form during
the noble boss battle so if you prefer
to battle palkia in that climactic
battle at the end instead and end up
using the origin ball on it make sure
that you pick the diamond clan when
given the option this way palkia comes
later regardless of who you pick you
will have the option to catch both
legendaries a first for diamond and
pearl
by default your wi-fi connection will be
off when playing legends arceus be sure
to turn it on that way other players can
return your lost satchels which are
important in netting mp points you can
use the mp points later to buy evolution
stones or evolution items such as
thunderstones reaper cloths metal coats
and so much more
as you go through the game's story
you'll unlock several different
locations such as the coronet highlands
or the cobalt coastland if you save the
game and fully back out and exit you'll
be greeted by a curated menu screen the
next time you log in the classic pokemon
legends arceus logo will appear on the
right with an image on the left of the
last section of the region that your
character saved its progress in
alright this is a fun one there's a
photo booth in juba life where you can
go in and pose for the camera even
putting on this like old timey filter
lens to give it a old-fashioned and
historical look talk to the photographer
and change your poser expression you can
even get your pokemon out there too to
pose with you and hilariously you can
have your pokemon played dead it looks
pretty damn funny simply select the
option for your pokemon as you set up
the photo and enjoy
now trust me when i say there are a lot
more things on this list that i'm saving
up for a part 2. so if you want to see
more and are interested in pokemon
legends arceus please let me know sound
off with anything you've picked up on
during your play time and i'll throw
them in a future list video meanwhile do
me a solid and check out some of our
other pokemon guides and reviews and for
everything else be sure to stay with
gamespot until next time
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
that's energy detected
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
huh
[Music]
huh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
wow
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
yep
[Music]
huh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a creature wanders restlessly through
the darkness
silver light illuminates the land and
the mountains
and with an entranced roar
it shows its true
[Music]
[Applause]
leave the beast to me
this is a royal matinee
we shall be in part soon
[Music]
this is our
outpost l gone
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cash
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
what's up
oh
[Music]
[Music]
bad boys
[Music]
it seems i'm unfashionably late
but i'm ready to give you everything
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
over the past five years breath of the
wild has been broken apart pretty
thoroughly by players with constant
discoveries of new glitches one of the
most sought after by far is weapon
duplication with the addition of the
weapon durability system that nintendo
implemented that causes weapons to break
easily players have wanted this glitch
more than ever and we've achieved it but
just how many ways are there to do this
most players think of just menu
overloading the most popular method by
far but there are tons of variations of
this and many other strange methods you
may not know so if you want more breath
of the wild videos from us let us know
by liking this one
let's start with one method that's not
quite as well known bone arm duplication
by breaking apart a stall enemy and
taking their arm just as they pick it up
the game will think that you took the
weapon but you are technically
empty-handed
so by switching your weapon and taking
the arm back the game thinks that you
have the arm equipped but you have a
different one instead which is called
inventory desync throw the weapon in
your hand on the ground and since it
thinks that you threw the bone arm the
duplicate weapon is then created
shock trap duplication was found early
in breath of the wild's life and made
farming for weapons with specific
modifiers much easier by swinging a
shock weapon and dropping it mid-swing
on something metallic its infinite shock
effects continually disarm enemies when
placed beneath their feet so by resting
at a campfire the enemy will repeatedly
drop the weapon over and over each new
day making a mountain pile of dropped
weapons
manual overloading is one of the most
used glitches with its versatility of
duplicating and transferring durability
of different weapons a glitch that is
highly sought after there are a ton of
different ways to trigger this from
enemy encampments using multi-shot shock
arrows dropping multi-shot shock arrows
yourself a mixture of the two dropping
two multi-shot shock bows with your back
to the wall and even escaping the final
boss fight then entering and exiting
certain areas hundreds of times triggers
menu overload once overloaded switching
and dropping weapons by throwing
shocking yourself putting it on a weapon
rack and more lets you duplicate the
selected weapon
octo balloon duplication is one of the
newer methods of multiplying your
weapons by having your back to a wall
using magnesis and dropping an octo
balloon this causes the balloon to drop
directly beneath your feet dropping a
weapon on this shortly after can give
you a chance to pick up the weapon off
the balloon twice duplicating the weapon
dynamic object duplication is a much
more simple technique but slightly more
tedious time-wise normally when opening
a treasure chest it's a one-and-done
deal and after taking the goods it never
appears again but by bringing any
dynamic object which includes some
treasure chests with equipment in them
two map grid spaces over in any
direction opening it then doesn't
actually count as taking it out so it's
possible to continuously grab the same
item over and over albeit with a little
bit of walking
the next three methods are based off the
same model teleport mechanic which is a
glitch that confuses the game on where
link's position actually is and giving
you a split second to de-sync equipment
on you one way to trigger this is the
horse lighting method horse sliding is a
glitch that lets you launch off your
horse in different ways this method can
be triggered by shield jumping on the
rear end of a horse while it's slanted
on a hill riding forward a small
distance then jumping off launching you
backwards towards your original position
but doing this as you over spur your
horse jumping off and throwing a weapon
at the same time then switching quickly
desyncs your held weapon now your thrown
weapon pops out but doesn't leave your
inventory because you technically had a
different weapon equipped so it becomes
duplicated
the standard model teleport method
requires using a horse at a slant
unequipping your shield at a specific
moment while link is tilting sideways
gives you a moment to de-sync and
perform a duplication glitch
always satisfying to see
finally pulse skewed duplication is
arguably the most difficult duplication
technique of all it consists of getting
a specific skew and skew setup to get a
reusable skew that flips link upside
down the combination of damaging
yourself with ragdoll glitch engaged
confuses the game on where link's
position actually is and gives you a
moment to desync and duplicate the
throne weapon i've done thousands of
glitches over the past several years but
this one was just too tough for me oh
well
what do you think of these weird methods
and how many of these did you know let
us know in the comments below and for
everything else gaming keep it here on
gamespot
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
after the hustle and bustle of e3 let's
slow down to a crawl here take a deep
breath and take an even closer look at
breath of the wild sequel between cross
referencing both trailers my personal
findings and people's theories posted
online i have a bit more information
about how things will go down in the
highly anticipated sequel this won't be
a 100 full breakdown of everything
rather more focused on interesting
points that i haven't seen too much
talked about yet we still do breath of
the wild content to this day so if you
want to see more from us let us know by
liking this video now let's take a
closer look even though there were only
short snippets of the ganondorf scene in
this trailer compared to the first
trailer these small scenes built more
context and answers that weren't so
clear from the first trailer alone using
reference points of when link's arm gets
affected by the new entity and the
malice and when we see ganondorf's
malice filled eyes are active we can
partially piece together what's
happening at the beginning of breath of
the wild sequel let's take a short look
at my possible version of what happened
then slow it back down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
now let's take a closer look and
describe some key scenes the first one
of note is this scene here where the
finger moves by the way zelda is acting
calmly and the shots before i'm very
sure the seal hand is still on ganondorf
at this point but the way this is
portrayed it seems ganondorf has some
powers and is able to slightly move
while sealed and or was triggered by the
arrival of link and zelda which is
understandable i mean this is possibly
the entirety of the triforce standing in
one room we're talking about here at
this point something happens and the
room starts to shake likely caused by
ganondorf and the ground gives way
causing zelda to fall through while link
goes to save her the most important
sequence happens next the seal hand
catches link putting two and two
together this is now highly likely that
the steelhand released ganondorf to try
and save zelda in link's fall although
now we know that it was only half
successful now that ganondorf is free of
the hand seal his eyes of malice come to
life as seen in the next shot of him
seemingly summoning more malicious
malice from the second trailer this is
likely when link was attacked as his
right arm is still normal at this time
and all throughout the game it seems
like this arm is fused with a ceiling
arm so this arm fusing is definitely the
last thing that happens at this point
it's pretty clear what happens next with
the malice spreading throughout hyrule
castle lifting it skyward it's possible
during or after this castle raising
sequence that link then fuses with the
entity fairly likely to cure the malice
that damaged his right hand since this
undergarment definitely gives off more
zonaish vibes than his normal blue
undergarments in this scene it's likely
he woke up in the sky which is often
shown off with this type of clothing
while this edit gives much more context
to the situation there are obviously
many elements missing so hopefully if
another trailer drops in the future we
can further build upon the story
clearly something has happened between
link and the master sword as this is the
final shot in the small timeline that we
have of link having the master sword
with him he has no gauntlet on his arm
compared to before possibly from the
previous mouse attack so this must have
happened after this shot so at this
point it is possible he is unable to
wield the sword of evil's bane after
being affected by malice since the sword
achieved and since these shots are
highly likely to happen in this order of
acquiring and then settling in the new
arm it's inferred that link passed out
and may have lost his equipment against
his will
which is an obvious reset point as the
beginning of the game an interesting
point with this situation though is if
there's ever a problem with the master
sword or it is misplaced it returns to
the korok forest but in this case as
proven in the trailer the deku tree is
gone and even possibly dead in the
sequel so maybe korok forest and
subsequently the sword pedestal could
have problems as well the fate of the
master sword is severely unclear at this
point we just don't know how it will
appear in the future
while there are many obvious and subtle
knowledge to previous games such as
twilight princess ocarina of time and
skyward sword i personally think that
miyazaki influences and themes and tones
are too large to ignore in the original
breath of the wild there were already so
many things that you could pick out that
shows miyazaki's influences but the
astounding thing is that in just two
small trailers for the sequel a game we
know barely anything about we've seen
references for two of miyazaki's films
multiple times princess mononoke and
castle in the sky from roots growing
through floating land masses filled with
stone paths to a pair of explorers going
through glowing caves and cursed
tendrils attacking the hero's arm the
nod to studio ghibli's work is still
undeniable
at this point it's pretty much confirmed
that the mysterious zonai or whatever
this racist name is has an integral part
in the upcoming sequel the references to
patterns and designs are really hard to
miss the zonai are an ancient warlike
tribe from the far on region and
architecture from their ruins in the
farang region are sparsely seen
throughout hyrule examples such as the
dragon's breath shield carvings on the
walls and this pillar design definitely
give off zonai's involvement dragons
also seem to have some general
importance as the music played at the
end of the trailer half of zelda's
lullaby is played by an erhu
[Music]
a chinese instrument that is also used
in the dragon's theme
this is telling because there are
already theories floating around the
dragon's portal and how that ties into
the world above these seams and
locations may hold some importance in
the future one thing that is confirmed
after staring at the shield for a while
is that this is not one piece of
equipment rather definitely an
attachment to a regular shield the
shield link is holding is definitely the
wooden shield but it is still unknown if
you are able to properly block with this
massive thing in front of you another
thing to think about is if bullet time
is returning there certainly wasn't
enough combat in this teaser to get any
concrete information but i'm wondering
if the slowdown mechanic is returning to
the sequel at all this backflip didn't
trigger any sort of flurry rush although
it could be a sidestep dodgeable attack
that they dodged incorrectly to not
trigger it or this attack isn't flurry
rushable at all nintendo has shown this
mechanic off in previous breath of the
wild original trailers so they may be
reworking mechanics behind the scenes or
the studio is simply not showing
everything off in these trailers
also an important note just by seeing
these islands in the sky are the
island's wall textures they seem very
unfriendly for climbing with aggressive
almost 45 degree walls at some points
and jagged edges with almost no places
to rest it's possible that these sides
are mechanically designed just like
shrine walls unclimbable and making you
fall down if you attempt to climb it if
that's true this empty gap where roads
end may require a special skill to cross
the gap of this size you couldn't just
jump and paraglide across this if the
walls are unclimbable while it could be
as simple as some magic bridge that
appears here i'm still crossing my
fingers for some sort of grapple arm
ability which with this creature's
similar energy and seemingly extendable
neck design could be a template for
link's extendable arm and this has been
in concept art before i mean crazier
concept art has come true so who knows
and those were all the points that i had
that were worth bringing up of course
we're very excited for the next trailer
and the final release so we'll be
delving very deep into the game when it
comes out as mentioned earlier we still
do tips tricks and breakdowns of the
first breath of the wild so stick around
for everything zelda and keep it here on
gamespot
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the cycle of this world i will not allow
it to perish with you
[Music]
i seek to destroy the irrational power
structure that shackles fodman
if the kingdom is ever to part ways with
our bloody past
this is the path we must walk
i have ambitions edelgard real ones
[Music]
will you sit around and wait for a
miracle
or will you help me seize control of my
fate
we shall fight
we shall survive and we shall win a
glorious future for foodland
now that i know
i won't make the same mistake again
[Music]
revenge is not a thing you take for
someone else
you seek revenge to slake your rage and
heal your wounded heart
i know you are prepared to do whatever
that you must
hello everyone i'm sheena takahashi and
i'll be your guide for today's nintendo
direct
what you just saw was the trailer for
the fire emblem warriors three hopes
game
[Music]
we hope you'll look forward to a
different story set in the same universe
as fire emblem three houses
let's see the first batch of nintendo
switch headlines
the orange star nation needs you
we've got more intel on the advance wars
oneplus 2 reap boot camp game
in the first campaign advance wars
you'll advise a colorful cast of
commanding officers and use their
abilities in vibrant turn-based battles
each commanding officer is now voiced
bringing even more charm to these
characters you're gonna get hurt i see
right through your plans another full
campaign awaits in advance wars 2 black
hole rising more commanding officers and
more diverse terrain can be leveraged
for additional tactical opportunities
like blasting through pipelines to cross
into enemy territory in both campaigns
you can fast forward gameplay and reset
your turns for a smoother tactical
experience
flex your strategic muscles outside of
both campaigns with additional modes
go for high scores in the war room
create and share custom maps in the
design room
or battle friends and frenemies in local
and online multiplayer
[Music]
advanced wars oneplus 2 reboot camp
marches onto the nintendo switch system
april 8th pre-orders are available now
on nintendoesha
[Music]
explore an infinite universe
in no man's sky
every star is the light of a distant sun
each orbited by planets teeming with
life
travel to planets of your choosing in
this infinite procedurally generated
universe here you'll discover
extraordinary lands and creatures that
have never been seen before and may
never be seen again
to survive
you must craft your own tools and even
your own place to live
[Music]
in this living and breathing universe
trade convoys travel between stars
factions vie for territory
pirates hunt unwary travelers
and the authorities are ever watchful
your journey may be fraught with danger
and actions have consequences
traitor
fighter
[Music]
explorer how will you live in this
universe
no man's sky lands on nintendo switch
this summer
um
uh
[Music]
[Music]
mario striker's battle league
prepare for strike a five-on-five sport
like soccer that's way heavy on offense
aim for goals by dribbling and passing
to teammates as well as by using tackles
items
and crushing special shots
the main rule in this sport is to rule
the field
try to score more goals than your
opponents
there are two things to keep in mind
that'll help you with your strategies
first the gear you equip it changes not
only your appearance but also your stats
like speed strength and pass accuracy
customize as you see fit
second
the hyper strike
to activate this shot grab an orb when
it appears on the field
and charge it while your opponents are
distracted
hit the net and you'll score not one but
two goals
up to eight players four players on each
team can compete against each other on
one nintendo switch system
in addition to individual matches online
play will have an online club mode
join an in-game club and compete for
placement in the rankings
up to 20 players can join a club so
create your own and invite friends and
family to play alongside you or join an
existing one owned by other players
try to become the world's tough club
with items
tackles
and hyper strikes
anything goes on this field
mario strikers battle league launches on
nintendo switch june 10th
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop
the latest iteration of the mario
strikers series is coming to nintendo
switch
we hope you're excited for this anything
goes battle soccer game
next please take a look at this
[Music]
do
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
that was the trailer for the co-op mode
in the splatoon 3 game the next wave of
salmon run
a giant salmonid one that's never been
seen before was also spotted at the end
of the trailer will the inklings and
octolings ink or swim splatoon 3 will
launch this summer we hope you'll look
forward to future updates
let's move on to more nintendo switch
headlines
fonzer's at the ready
a full remake of the first front mission
game is storming onto nintendo switch
in this tactical rpg you'll pilot
weaponized machines called vonsers and
lead your battalion to victory
[Music]
gain the upper hand in battle by aiming
for enemy parts to destroy
mix and match various weapons and parts
to customize your vonser
uncover the great storyline of this
classic when front mission one remake
launches on nintendo switch this summer
and in the future the sequel front
mission 2 remake will also launch on
nintendo switch
[Music]
get set for a high-octane disney and
pixar combat racer
from the creators of the asphalt series
comes rip roaring racing action across
disney and pixar inspired race tracks
race as a legendary roster of characters
on high-speed circuits using each one's
special abilities to battle for victory
across the finish line
choose mickey mouse for symphonic speed
sully for monstrous power or mulan for
explosive maneuvers
each racer also possesses powerful
ultimate skills perfect for turning the
tables at the last second
disney speedstorm is a free-to-play game
with new seasons added regularly
bringing more exciting disney and pixar
characters
circuits carts and more
plus enjoy cross-platform play as well
as split screen and online multiplayer
modes
disney speed storm races onto nintendo
switch this summer
dive into these classic franchises on
nintendo switch
unleash the power of the force in this
classic star wars action adventure as
darth vader's secret apprentice you'll
use devastating force powers and
lightsaber combos as you hunt down jedi
masters on iconic planets
upgrade abilities like force grip and
force repulse then combine them for even
more destructive combos
use button controls or opt for motion
controls enhanced from the original wii
version
you can also dual locally with a friend
to determine who is the galaxy's most
powerful jedi
star wars the force unleashed launches a
nintendo switch april 20th pre-orders
begin today on nintendo eshop the
complete saga of legendary assassin ezio
auditore da frenze awaits in three
critically acclaimed assassins creed
games
explore renaissance italy and 16th
century constantinople interact with
historical figures and discover secrets
of the creed across three games two
bonus short films
and dlc
plus take advantage of enhanced features
for the nintendo switch system on the go
including touch screen controls hd
rumble and optimized on-screen display
assassin's creed the ezio collection
launches a nintendo switch february 17th
pilot mobile suits in dynamic action rpg
battles
strange incidents called breaks are
occurring across the gundam universe
find out what's causing them and restore
the proper timeline you'll need three
mobile suits in battle
enhance each suit with parts to improve
their power you can also battle
alongside friends in online co-op
multiplayer sd gundam battle alliance
launches a nintendo switch this year
[Music]
two worlds cross in the triumphant
return of this rpg classic
a remaster of the acclaimed rpg chrono
cross is coming to the nintendo switch
system
one fateful day the protagonist surge
wanders into an alternate world
though it somewhat resembles his
homeworld he finds that he no longer
exists here
how did this happen
what is this mysterious another world
travel back and forth between both
worlds to unravel the story
over 40 characters can join your party
depending on the choices you make the
allies who accompany you and the endings
that trigger will differ
a number of improvements have been made
to this remaster
like the ability to turn off enemy
encounters and a newly enhanced
soundtrack
plus radical dreamers originally
released on the citella view is included
experience the origins of chronocross in
this text-based adventure
chronocross the radical dreamers edition
dashes and slashes its way onto nintendo
switch april 7th
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop
[Music]
it's kirby's latest unforgettable 3d
platforming adventure kirby and the
forgotten land
it all takes place in a mysterious world
with an unusual mix of nature and
civilization
to rescue the kidnapped waddle dees
kirby sets off on a new adventure
[Applause]
introducing
mouthful mode
inhale a car to zoom around
[Music]
a vending machine to attack with juice
cans
or become a piercing cone
with mouthful mode new actions will be
available for kirby depending on the
object he inhales
enjoy exploring with new moves different
from copy abilities
kirby can even weaponize a mouthful of
water like this
as kirby rescues waddle dees waddle
d-town will continue to grow and more
resources will become available
at waddle dee's weapon shop familiar
copy abilities can be evolved
[Music]
evolve copy abilities to expand kirby's
range of attacks
they'll also change kirby's appearance
and make him even more powerful
some copy abilities may have stronger
involved forms
a new adventure awaits our pink puffball
[Music]
who are the beasts back
what are these enemies trying to do
[Music]
can kirby restore peace to this world
kirby and the forgotten land launches on
the nintendo switch system march 25th
pre-orders are available now on nintendo
eshop
that was kirby and the forgotten land
launching later next month
please look forward to its release
let's take a look at some more nintendo
switch headlines
nintendo director
that's right ohtani son mlb the show was
coming to nintendo's switch that means
you could play modes like road to the
show and diamond dynasty on your
nintendo switch but that's not all you
can even play exhibition with a single
joy-con controller with
cross-progression you can also earn and
use content on any platform where mlb
the show 22 is available and take your
progress on the go with you on nintendo
switch have friends that play mlb the
show 22 online matches on other consoles
no need to worry you can invite them and
play online
[Music]
i knew you were a true two-way player
but this is ridiculous
sheesh
[Music]
you're gonna have your hands full of
games with these collections
three kingdom hearts collections are
almost here
from kingdom hearts to kingdom hearts 3
and the remind dlc every entry is coming
to nintendo switch as cloud versions
that can be played while connected to
the internet
relive or get to know these heart-filled
adventures alongside sora donald goofy
and more for the first time in tv
tabletop or handheld mode
kingdom hearts intragram masterpiece for
cloud containing all three game
collections soars onto nintendo switch
tomorrow
each collection's cloud version will
also be individually available on
nintendo eshop
clinoa is coming to nintendo switch
across dreamy side scrolling levels
you'll run jump and hover while firing
wind bullets to grab and throw enemies
use each level surroundings to your
advantage
[Music]
also clinoa 2 is included
take on these great adventures when
clinoa fantasy reverie series launches a
nintendo switch july 8th
we're so glad you're here
come here often
either way you're in for a puzzling
treat
in these award-winning games the portal
gun is your key to surviving
imprisonment in a mysterious lab
create portals and warp to other areas
to find
cake
still unconfirmed you can pass through
portals and so can cubes lasers and
robots with unnerving levels of
personality
the sequel adds in local online and
split screen multiplayer modes and that
part's no lie
neither is the sentient robot monitoring
your every move when portal companion
collection warps onto nintendo switch
this year
a classic comes alive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
previously unreleased outside of japan
the rpg live alive makes its overseas
debut now in hd 2d multiple stories
featuring different protagonists and
time periods await the order in which
you tackle them is up to you pre-history
a tribesman comes of age in a world
without words
the wild west a wanderer with a bounty
on his head fights for his life
imperial china a kung fu master searches
for a worthy successor
twilight of edo japan as shinobi
undertakes an important secret mission
present day a martial artist strives to
become the strongest there ever was
the near future a youth with psychic
powers takes a stand against evil the
distant future a newly built robot is
swept up in a tragedy in space
what other stories are on the horizon
[Music]
will repay my loyalty
in death
live alive launches on nintendo switch
july 22nd
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop
how was that
next up is this
it's a new iteration of the wii sports
series
nintendo switch sports
please take a look
[Music]
here are the sports included in the
nintendo switch sports game
you might recognize these three from
past wii sports games
tennis rally by gently swinging the
joy-con controller at the right time
[Music]
bowling
roll the ball straight ahead or give it
a little curve
and chambra
knock your opponent off the platform
while attacking and defending
plus three additional sports are joining
the lineup
[Music]
soccer
use a gigantic ball to make dynamic
plays
enjoy matches with joy-con controllers
to shoot and perform diving headers
by attaching a joy-con controller to the
leg strap accessory included with the
physical version of the game you can
play shootout mode with intuitive
kicking motions
badminton
control your shots left and right while
keeping the shuttlecock in the air
unleash powerful smash shots to gain the
upper hand
[Music]
finally volleyball
use a joy-con controller to serve
bump
set
and spike the ball
[Music]
the game supports local play with family
and friends on one nintendo switch
system as well as online play across all
sports
play against friends online
or
opt for random matchmaking
the more you win the tougher the players
you'll face
[Music]
try taking on this challenge
[Music]
how was that since i'm already here i'd
like to show you some gameplay of one of
the newly added sports
volleyball mr takahashi
oh
hello there everyone i'm yoshiaki
koizumi from nintendo wow mr koizumi i
can see you're ready to play
alright i'll play some volleyball online
together with mr koizumi
do you have your wrist strap ready
yes of course
i've got plenty of space around me as
well
all right let's start we'll be including
some live commentary throughout our
match
all right oh we're doing this uh
volleyball a newly added sport in
nintendo switch sports
what can we expect today from the
takahashi koizumi team
it's koizumi to serve with takahashi up
front
we begin with koizumi serving
how will the opposing team react
takahachi makes the block
another one's coming
koizumi saves it let's set up in the air
and here comes the spike
the other team saves it and fights back
and they score
takahashi didn't quite get it in time
all right well it's okay it's okay the
game's not over
now the other team serves
koizumi receives it takahashi sets it up
and kozumi spikes but it goes right
toward the opponent here's another
attack
now's their chance they get the ball
and with the setup from koizumi
takahashi scores
they got a point with that fierce spike
let's stop our match here after all we
were in the middle of a presentation
all right i'll be leaving now
that was an introduction to nintendo
switch sports
the game launches april 29th
we're planning a free update in the
summer that allows you to play soccer
matches with a joy-con controller and
the leg strap accessory you can use the
accessory to play shootout mode at
launch
in addition
we're also planning a second free update
this fall that lets you enjoy golf
[Music]
and now a request to everyone to help
ensure that you can all enjoy playing
online we'll be having an online play
test before the game launches to
evaluate various technical aspects
we definitely like to ask for your help
with this
the online playtest will only be
available for players with an active
nintendo switch online membership on the
dates shown on screen
for those of you interested please visit
the official nintendo website for more
details
that's all i have for now about nintendo
switch sports
i hope you're looking forward to this
game
let's see a few more nintendo switch
headings
get those taigo drumming skills ready
the latest taikuno toxigen game is
coming to the nintendo switch system set
in omeko city a sacred town for taiko
drums you'll strive to become a taiko
master along with brand new character
kumokun
drum to dozens of poppin beats including
megalovania guerengae feel special and
racing into the night and that's not all
an orchestral version of the main theme
from the legend of zelda is included
that's 76 songs total
plus take advantage of a practice mode
to replace sections of songs as many
times as you'd like
new modes have also been added for
everyone to enjoy put on a live concert
with up to four players in donchen band
or face off against each other in great
drum toy war
[Music]
drum to your heart's content
when taiko no tatsujin rhythm festival
launches on nintendo switch this year
plus a paid in-game subscription service
that gives you access to over 500 songs
will be available at launch
[Music]
what's new with these nintendo switch
games
the brand new tactical rpg game triangle
strategy is almost here
the protagonist sarah noah and his
allies will be engulfed in the conflict
among three nations your choices and
conviction will determine their fate as
lord of house wolford i solemnly swear
an oath by which all future lords shall
be bound i will never turn my back on
the promise of a better world a new demo
playable to the end of chapter 3 will be
available on nintendo eshop later today
save data from the demo can be
transferred to the full game once
purchased
more cuphead action awaits in the paid
dlc cuphead the delicious last course
here you'll explore a brand new inkwell
isle defeat a bevy of new bosses with
wild personalities and even wilder
attacks
the clever miss chalice is a new
playable character
take down fearsome foes with her double
jumps rolling dodges and more
cuphead the delicious last course
wallops its way onto nintendo switch
june 30th
[Music]
a free update is coming to the metroid
dread game
all it takes is one hit
even from this
getting hit even once causes a game over
in the brutal dread mode difficulty
can you face this new challenge
and for players new to the metroid
series take advantage of increased
recovery with the newly added rookie
mode difficulty
this free update launches later today
[Music]
a second free update in april will add a
boss rush mode in which you'll battle
bosses continuously one at a time
[Music]
something's bound for nintendo switch
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
earthbound and earthbound beginnings
will be added to nintendo switch online
later today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what did you think
here's some news from mario kart fans
many of you have been enjoying the mario
kart 8 deluxe game since its launch in
2017.
so
we've been working on remastering select
courses from across the mario kart
series and we'll be releasing them as
paid downloadable content
please take a look at this trailer
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
paid dlc courses will be coming to mario
kart 8 deluxe
this is the mario kart 8 deluxe booster
course pass
you may recognize some courses from past
mario kart games
eight courses will be released at a time
over six waves that's 48 additional
courses we plan on releasing by the end
of 2023
courses such as coconut mall
[Music]
chaco mountain
[Music]
and tokyo blur will be included in the
first wave
of course you can play these courses
locally and online
[Music]
the first wave of the mario kart 8
deluxe booster course pass will launch
march 18th
pre-orders begin today a nintendo eshop
you can enjoy this dlc at no additional
cost with a nintendo switch online plus
expansion pack membership or purchase
the mario kart 8 deluxe booster course
pass on its own
[Music]
how was that
i hope you're looking forward to the
additional courses in mario kart 8
deluxe
this next segment will be our last
announcement
please take a look
[Music]
fighting in order to
live and living to fight
[Music]
that's the way of our world
ionios
tell me
what would possess you to side with them
we're fighting because there are enemies
to kill i refuse to believe you're him
i knew it i saw this coming you are
you're not enemies now fine for you
isn't it all that time you've got you
could try try to move forwards again how
can our lives
nothing little do you they're not your
friends anymore they're his few
sword march
the land pierced by a great sword
it's the only way you're gonna defeat
the real enemy
life is lost i won't let you sold it all
alone what could filling up these
flickering clocks in our eyes it will
never replace the predatory block the
same clock it has to go
uroboros are bore this world
they must be erased without a trace
[Music]
the story of xenoblade chronicles 3 ties
together the futures of the worlds
depicted in xenoblade chronicles and
xenoblade chronicles 2 and it will
launch this september i hope you'll look
forward to it
that's all for today's nintendo direct
thank you for watching
[Music]
you